all right hi everyone
my name is Philip I work for anaconda as
a consultant but on the side work on
various open source projects of which
panel is one
it's a project I started about a year
ago learning from some of the experience
I've had we're consulting for various
clients to solve issues I've seen over
and over again in various data science
workflows so who of you has a Jupiter
dashboard with the plot in it okay
that's good or a table and image an
equation whatever well let's do you I
thought so and maybe you might want to
explore these things or share them with
people is that common need I would think
so so panel is for you then so a panel
as I said is a pretty new library it's
built on bouquet which is generally
thought of as a potting library but
there's actually a lot more behind
bouquet and panel basically let's your
notebooks double as apps or dashboards
and so you you can use just about any
plotting library image type or other
objects and embed it in a panel so the
comparison I mean we've just had that an
excellent talk about - the comparison to
- obviously becomes pretty obvious and
so I might as well address it right away
what we try to do is we try to kind of
address meet people closer to where they
are already so they already have a
notebook they have some analysis in
their notebook and they want to kind of
create a little doubt dashboard or app
that they want to share with people and
then revise and kind of adjust things in
the dashboard in the notebook and then
revise repeats and kind of build a
dashboard that way so while it's we've
geared it towards usage in Jupiter
notebooks it's not actually it doesn't
require Jupiter notebooks um you can
just write a Python script and deploy
that just like you could with a bouquet
out so before I go through like the
typical workflow that you have with
panels with a panel usually I'm going to
quickly take you through some demos of
the kind of things you can achieve with
panel okay so on the panel website we
have a nice little gallery of some more
sophisticated examples we're actively
building this out so I announced panel
about six months ago
and we're actively working on kind of
improving examples examples of simple
apps and on various the usages the
various API is that panel provides how
to build dynamic you eyes and so on so
that's quite nice and one thing you need
to know about panel is basically it
consists of three different types of
objects the first or panes basically the
paintings provide a view onto some
objects you've got some plots on bulk a
plot plot leap lot bigger plot whatever
you put an in a panel in a pain and that
visualizes it inside panel then there's
the layouts and currently there's the
columns rows tabs widget boxes and so on
and then there's the widgets which give
you the interactivity you might want so
there's a whole range and we're actively
expanding these ok then we have a
website of various examples on examples
that pipe is org so these are more
involved examples that kind of take some
subject matter and go through them and
then I'm really gonna take you through
some examples so this is a panel app
we're running on Bakke server where I
have a few demos lined up so the first
time I'm going to show you is this get
winder demo so here we've embedded four
different plots from different libraries
here first one is generate using HP plot
as a bouquet plot interactive police
embedded Altair a bigger plot imapilot
plot and a plot li plot and we've looked
linked it to this widget so if I drag
this all the four different plots update
and so whatever blog calling whatever
you use I'm one of the common ones in
Python the panel will just support your
current needs meet you where you are
basically another nice dent and what
we've built is this cross filtering demo
this is basically all the world's
glaciers and you this plot is generate
using data shader so it's it's several
hundred thousand data points but the
initiator will scale to millions and
basically allows you to cross filter on
these so the nice thing this demonstrate
is you can embed your plots in here they
all they can be linked so you can have
interactions on the plots themselves
either using bouquet or plotly you can
have updating text and you can have
buttons and so on so the other nice
thing is because this is all built on
top of bouquet which has a really nice
layout engine you can see that when I
drag this these plots are responsive and
everything up updates as I drag it
around so the next demo I'm going to
show you is a portfolio optimizer
basically the idea here is that if you
have the stock dataset you have a very
stock so you can upload in low file but
the thing that this is meant to
demonstrate is again you can have plots
you can have buttons you can upload
things but also you can have tabs for
example if you can't fit something on a
page it'll let you lay things out in
this way okay and then finally I'm gonna
show you a more involved demo which is
this dashboard we built or someone else
built for the LSST
this is the largest telescope in the
world it's currently being built and so
they want to analyze quite a lot of data
they have billions of stories obviously
that they're scanning for and so this is
a bit more involved app but uses
something called templates which I'll
show you later but basically this allows
you to do more complex things so here
we're cross filtering a couple million
points and so when I track this you'll
see the other plots update and response
you can do quite complex things so this
is not the standard thing laying things
out with rows and columns but rather
we're actually embedding things in a
template and I'll show you how that
works in a bit okay so going from there
I'm gonna take you through the standard
workflow that you have a panel so we're
gonna start with the data set as you so
often do so here this data set I don't
know how well you can see this increase
the size a little bit so this data set
is basically just a common data set of
room occupancy it's basically
measurements in a room as people go in
and out of this room measurements like
temperature humidity lights co2 it's
just an example it's just
trying to show you what the workflow
might be um so what we've already done
is we've already got a notebook we've
already done someone else's right so
we've got a clotting function we've got
some little analysis so to put but this
is doesn't really matter but I'll
quickly take you through it so we've
taken the rolling mean of this over time
then computed residual and then we're
trying to find outliers by basically
taking points that are away from this
rolling mean by a certain number of
standard deviations and so we've already
got this we got this function ooh what
what doesn't actually run this so we got
a much fuller plot easy enough
everyone's familiar but now you need to
share this with your boss or your boss's
boss who doesn't know that code he
doesn't want to go and manually edit
this rolling window or pick a different
variable or whatever so you might want
to explore this in a nicer way so as a
starting point you can simply say PM
gonna interact give it this function and
it creates some witness for you if
you're familiar with I PI widgets this
is basically the same thing I kind of
inspects the function that's pretty
magic and it gives you fine it's a good
start
it's interact is being as magic as it is
kind of doesn't know that a window can't
be negative really or that Sigma Z you
shouldn't use a negative Sigma this
dataset doesn't really make sense so
what we're gonna do is actually give it
some additional information we're gonna
tell it basically the window size
shouldn't be should be between 1 and 60
we're going to tell this various
variables that we have in this data set
the range of the Sigma values I'm never
going to run it again cool bit more
useful we can now pick the different
variables these are now in a sensible
range and we've got a goodly right we
could we could share this with our boss
which is fine so we're going to do that
and we're going to see what that looks
like so if you run the dot show command
on this object what you get is a
separate server a bulky server is
started up and you can see what this
Apple looks like so within just two
lines of code we've now generated this
little app
which is interactive and kind of does
something that we want but it's not very
pretty right and our boss doesn't he
doesn't really understand what the
segment value is sorry I had a little
bit of text but before that we're going
to look at inspect what this actual
object is right we've run this
interactive thing or we've gotten
something back and it visualized itself
and it all seems rather magic but what
this actually is if you print it is a
column which contains another column and
in this column are the widgets and then
in this and then there's this bro in it
as well which contains the metal lip
plot that we were showing right and then
you can also see here that we've got
these nice little indexes which tell us
how to index into this object so we can
unpack what we've gotten from this
interact thing and then build something
that's actually kind of nicer so that's
we're gonna do here we're gonna add some
text to find some markdown text unpack
our little interact objects get the
first column the the row I'm continuing
the plots and then put that next to the
text with two of the widgets because
again Arts Boston understand what a
sigma is so we're going to just ignore
that and just use two of the variables
right so now we've got something that's
a bit nicer but prettier we can actually
show this to someone right so that's a
good start and we can now again use show
to show this in lo app and share it with
someone what we can also do is we've as
I said we've dropped this little this
extra widget but actually because things
are linked you can have things linked
across cells so maybe do something else
here so things stay linked across cells
and also note that because everything is
linked as well you can also just change
the variable from Python so
programmatically we can still alter the
widgets and things update okay so so far
we've done everything with interact as I
said it's kind of a magic thing it's
kind of it does some crazy stuff inside
it does his introspection and things and
maybe you want to be more explicit right
you want to declare some widgets that
you declared yourself so here what we're
going to do is
declare a variable widget which is
basically read your button group see
what that looks like in a minute an
inflator
and then this is fairly similar to what
you saw with - in the last talk
basically you create a reactive function
where you say actually this function
depends on these two widgets so whenever
these widgets change
I want this function to be reacts acute
and Rifat to update so that's what
you've done here I've got this reactive
function and then we can just put this
reactive function in one in our layout
and panel we'll know to inspect the
decorated thing and find out what it
should listen to and so we do that we
again get I need remember to run these
things we again get our little app in
this time we've got a nice different
widget and so on okay
so throughout this entire workflow we've
used my for loop which is nice and fine
but maybe we want to use something else
maybe we just want to swap out for a
different library so what we're going to
use here is HV plot HV plot is basically
a drop-in replacement for the plumper
kind of stop plot function but it also
works on x-rays - data frames intake geo
pandas so it's a really neat thing that
we've been building as well which you
can check out and so what we've done is
simply we're going to swap the plotting
function we had before out for one that
uses HV plot to plot this mean and
average and now we get an app that's now
interactive we've got a little
interactive okay plot here we can zoom
and pan and do all the nice things like
inspect the individual data points and
so on and so whatever like plugin
library use you can just drop it in and
it'll just display okay
so this was just an example of an
example workflow that you might have you
probably already have a bunch of
notebooks with some outputs and ports
and tables in them you can just drop
those in there but once you've actually
so we've seen the dot show part like how
do I basically stand up the server
really quick to look at what it would
look like as a standalone app but now I
want to run it and deploy it somewhere
right and so what you can do is you can
simply instead of adding Dutch show at
the end of your little object you can
say dot servable
and what that means is then that
particular objects will get picked up
when you execute this thing so when I
run panel dot serve on this notebook now
again I'll get the fully deployed app
running in a fairly scalable way so what
this shows is that panel basically can
take you through your entire data data
analysis workflow you can start by just
using your standard tools then drop them
into a panel add some widgets cemetry
activity to your thing and finally you
can deploy it to be shared within your
organization or in some cases even
outside of it okay so I'm going to show
you some other features that kind of
make tunnel quite nice and stand apart
from some other tools so one thing you
can do what we've seen so far is
everything we need it calls back into
place every time you change a widget it
has to go back to python just like you
saw on the - talk ask it what what what
is the updates that I need to apply and
so on which is fine if you want to
deploy dashboard but if you've got a
simple little app that doesn't seem that
important right do you don't really want
to stand up a whole web server just to
do that and it's just a simple - it's
got like ten different states or
whatever so what we're gonna do is say
actually I want to embed the output in
here so what is this doing now is it's
actually we can actually see what it's
doing so you can see here it's actually
going through the different states of
these different widgets recording what
the state at every stage is and then
embedding that output into either the
notebook or you can have a system long
HTML file where all this output is saved
into or even have it export to Jason so
that every time you change the widget it
goes fetches that update from the JSON
file so you update it so you don't need
to actually have a full server you can
simply say embed and then you do you
don't need the web server with it so I'm
gonna have to let this finish um so if
you want to instead you can also say
save this so currently this would get
all and get embedded into this notebook
itself what you can also do is say
actually I want to save this into a
separate file and then I want to embed
this as well so this should be just
about finished now
let it go through the final states okay
so it's now yes so now obviously if you
have a million different states that's
not a sensible thing to do in this case
what it's done is basically soundpool
the the parameter space in a fairly
discreet way you can also tell it to
sound a little bit more and so on so
embedding is a quite nice thing for a
simple app that you just want shares an
HTML file so another nice feature um is
template so you saw an example of that
earlier but I'll briefly take you
through how that actually works so so
far we've built all our the deep in the
art worked example workflow we've built
everything using drills and columns but
actually if you wanted to have a nice
little template around it make it look a
bit more pretty you might want to drop
it into an actual HTML template so in
this case what we've done is we've used
material wise which is basically an
implication of the material UI style and
then the way this works is you basically
you just the ginger template so you
extend it a little bit you extend the
basic template then you can say you can
either say basically just iterate over
all the plots or panels that I've added
to this template or you can explicitly
give it a name so you can say here in
this place insert the bigger plot at
this place insert the plotly plot or
whatever you have so in this case we've
we've done that we've declared over a
number of plots a bigger plot a plot Lee
part of all of these plot we can then
say so this currently doesn't render in
the notebook yet but we can launch it as
a separate server so here we now have a
nice little a nicer looking UI on top of
things we have our bigger plot in there
we've got a report leap lot in there
nice little 3d plot and then we've got a
nice little all of use app base built on
bouquet which allows you to basically
interactively zoom and pan kind of
explore really quite large large data
sets and filter and change the color map
since our so let me go back
ok so these are some of the features
that panel will support going forward
weird so obviously panel is still a
pretty young project we're still
actively building out our documentation
we want to have detailed guides on how
to actually deploy this thing on
different cloud services
so if you want to help with that join us
at the sprints on the weekend we also
we're going to build some more examples
and expand the gallery and another nice
thing that we want to do is kind of add
more components and part of that work is
where we're actually so we've been
engaging with some of the Jupiter folks
to kind of support Jupiter widgets in
bidirectionally which means so Jupiter
Jupiter I would say ecosystem is fairly
large they've built a lot of nice
components and it would be nice if we
could reuse ups right so the idea is
that not only are you going to be able
to put your panel app inside an eye-fi
widget and then deploy it using some of
their solutions for - for deployment but
you're also going to be able to put
Jupiter widgets inside panel to kind of
reuse that ecosystem so that's something
I do and finally I want to compare a
little bit so we just had a talk on -
there's also the Jupiter folks have been
building something called Bala which
America also makes it easy to kind of
deploy your dashboards your notebooks as
a deaf board but before I do that
comparison I just want to say how really
great it is to see that the Python
ecosystem finally has these solutions
right or is it such a tiny for years and
years and years and finally we were
seeing these these solutions emerge in
the Python ecosystem so while I'm gonna
be compared doing some comparisons I
definitely do not want to denigrate the
other libraries - is super nice to build
probably more complex apps and panel
will let you do well that makes it super
easy to just say bolus or my notebook
you don't need to do any extra notation
and so on but there are some differences
right so compared to - you saw - is kind
of kind of closely tied
to the kind of structure you see in a
HTML Dom tree so it's pretty closely try
it to HTML concepts I think panel is a
bit more pythonic and less more concise
in some ways and also panel lets you use
I've already plotting libraries just out
of the box and you can also embed panel
things in line in a notebook so you
don't if you don't actually want to
deploy this thing you can do some stuff
just in a notebook current so it's it's
kind of more geared towards this full
full lifecycle of a data analysis
workflow where you start in the notebook
and then you kind of explore a bit and
then finally you might deploy this thing
right and then I also want to compare it
to vallah avila is also really nice
library they've been doing a lot of work
to make it work well
valla is tied to the Jupiter ecosystem
so which means that basically it just
runs the Jupiter server it starts a
kernel for each for each user or each
session that started and so unlike that
panel will start a separate bulky server
which means it doesn't necessarily have
that overhead of starting a kernel for
each user which can be somewhat
significant and it also means you can
panel will let you share data across
different users right you've got some
computation you've got some data that's
expensive to load uses a lot of memory
you can share that and then reuse it and
then finally the final difference is
Bulldog usually just serves every all
the output in your notebook so if you
want to kind of narrow down what you
want to serve you buy the templates and
kind of old so both have trade-offs but
impound all you basically designate this
is my output this is what I want to
actually serve in the end okay so thanks
everyone
you can funnel an HB plot or which I've
shown today or just some of the
libraries that we work on we also work
on libraries like data shader which did
the nice resampling that you saw earlier
hollow use geo views per arm color set
so check those out and go visit us at
Halle visit org it provides a nice
tutorial taken through you through these
tools
you can find me on Twitter and github
under Philip Jennifer and this is my
email doesn't even have questions any
yeah thanks for the great talk if you're
using the save option saving the HTML
file and using embed equals true what
what's like a practical limit for how
large of a data set you could embed that
is a pretty good question so I haven't
scaled it up so thousand different
states the sensible alright it's not too
crazy especially if you can then spill
that out to some JSON files so you can
just dump those somewhere at web server
or something but it certainly won't
scale to like if you want to have 5
widgets which you have a hundred
different states I mean that's the
combinatorial explosion and it's crazy
right so it's really geared to smaller
you just wanted one off thing that you
want to send to someone hi you mentioned
some new features that you want to
implement could you give some examples
of what you see happening in the future
sure so one of the things we really want
to push on is the I PI widgets
integration but then different
components so some of the components I
want is I want in editable tables some
other things I can imagine we definitely
want to push the templates templating
but further so I'm currently working on
for example being able to show the
templates inside a notebook so you can
kind of see what it's going to look like
and then deploy it but beyond that it's
keep really driven by users so we've had
various users can contribute new
components things like a vtk renderer
any plotting libraries that you want to
bed so it's really driven by users needs
[Music]
thank you again for this great talk this
is definitely a - I want to try out one
question would be if I want to use this
in a set of semi production environment
just show it to some customer or
something on the bed is there a simple
way of implementing some basic
authentication with this yes so this is
something that well right now no but in
about two weeks
okay so since it's built on top of
Boquete we get all the nice features at
the boca team implements for free and
they've just implemented an auth
provider so you can simply basically
write a little tornado off provider and
then you get it for free so we're gonna
have examples on them very very soon in
the next couple weeks all right thank
you very much just think if it of it was
amazing presentation so let's give it a
plus or speaking of once more and have a
nice lunch guys girls
[Applause]